من ساعه شاهد الاردن والعالم العربي عقد
قران الامير الحسين بن عبد الله الثاني
وكان عقد القران بدا بوصول الملك عبد الله
والملكه رانيا الى قصر زهران لاستقبال
الضيوف ومن بعدها وصل الامير الحسين لقصر
زهران وكان لابس الزي العسكري وبعدين وصلت
العروس بفستان زفاف من توقيع الي صعب مصمم
لها خصيصا وقدمها لعريسها شقيق الامير
هاشم وتم بعدين عقد القران اللي اشرف عليه
امام الحضره الهاشميه احمد الخلايله وشهد
على عقد القران الملك عبد الله الثاني
والامير حسن عم الملك عبد الله وذلك بحضور
140 ضيف بما فيهم اعضاء العائله الهاشميه
[تصفيق]
جابر الخواطر شان ابيه وذويه واجداده
الاكابر ومبارك زواجه بكريمه الاصل زوجتك
ابنه رجوه ابنه رجوى على كتاب الله على
كتاب الله وعلى سنه رسوله وعلى سنه رسوله
صلى الله عليه وسلم صلى الله عليه وسلم
وعلى المهر وعلى المهر المسمى بيننا
المسمى بيننا سيدي سمو الامير
لو خاطبت سعاده الشيخ قائلا وانا وانا
قبلت الزواج
منها منها لنفسي لنفسي على كتاب الله على
كتاب الله وسنه رسوله وسنه رسوله صلى الله
عليه وسلم صلى الله عليه وسلم وعلى المهر
وعلى المهر المسمى بين المسمى بيننا مبارك
[تصفيق]
ومن دقائق صدرت الاراده الملكيه بالانعام
على رجوه بنت خالد السيف بلقب صاحبه السمو
الملكي الاميره رجوه الحسين المعظمه هو من
دقائق انطلق او بعد دقائق عفوا مشاهدينا
سينطلق الموكب الاحمر لكل الاردنيين
بينتظروه بفارغ الصبر وهو تقليد ملكي يعني
عريق من تاسيس الدوله بيتكون من 20 سياره
كلاسيكيه حمراء مع عشر دراجات ناريه فيهم
العشرات من عناصر الحرس الملكي اللي
حيرافقوا سياره ولي العهد وعروسته في
مسيره ملكيه من قصر زهران اللي شهد زواج
الجد والاب والحفيد بنتكلم عن الملك
الراحل الحسين والملك عبد الله والان ولي
العهد الحسين بن عبد الله الموكب بعد
دقائق مشاهدينا سيتجه نحو قصر الحسينيه
اللي راح يكون في الاحتفال الرسمي بالزفاف
ونشاهد الان صور مباشره والالاف الاردنيين
وهم في انتظار الموكب في الشوارع وهم
بيحتفلوا طبعا في هاشتاق والاحتفالات كلها
تحت كانت اسم نفرح بالحسين الحفل حيكون في
قصر الحسينيه وهذا الحفل راح يبدا بمجرد
وصول العروسين بزفه ملكيه ومن بعدها حيتم
اصطحاب العروسين لساحه الاستقبال في القصر
وحترافقهم زفه عسكريه مرورا بتقليد حمله
السيوفه دي يعني واحد من التقاليد
المستخدمه في الاردن وفي زفاف الامراء
تحديدا ايضا مشاهدينا طبعا نحن بنشاهد
الان هذه الاحتفالات شعبيه والاغاني
والاعلام وحتكون في سبع مواقع مختلفه هيمر
عليها الموكب وطبعا بعدها زي ما قلت
مشاهدينا راح يصلوا الى طبعا قصر الحسينيه
هناك في قصر الحسينيه كمان راح يكون في
مشاركه
للفنانين طبعا الفنان الكبير محمد عبده و
الفنان الاردني عمر عبد الله في الزفه راح
يقدمه اغنيه مشتركه للزفه بتمثل الثقافتين
السعوديه
والاردنيه عند دخول
العروسين وهذه حتكون الزفه طبعا احنا قبل
دقائق مشاهدينا كمان شهدنا مراسم عقد
القران شاهدنا توافد الضيوف اولا بعدين
عقد القران بعدين جهدنا العريس والعروسه
طلعوا ووقفوا وسلموا على الضيوف طبعا كل
الضيوف اللي حضروا الزواج وخلينا تحديدا
بنتكلم نحن طبعا من اكثر من 70 دوله طبعا
كان في من الاسره الهاشميه كان في من اسره
العروسه طبعا الاميره رجوى خلينا نرجع
لموضوع المدعوين تحديدا مشاهدينا احنا اذا
بنتكلم الان عن بالنسبه للضيوف اللي كانوا
مدعومين لحضور حفل الزفاف نحن زي ما ذكرت
مشاهدينا اكثر من 70 دوله بينهم طبعا ملوك
امراء اعضاء عائلات حاكمه رؤساء مسؤولين
الحفل مدعو عليه حيكون 1700 ضيف من بينهم
طبعا من اللي حضروا ايضا كمان شفناهم في
عقد القران ولي عهد ابو ظبي ولي عهد
البحرين طبعا السيده الاولى للولايات
المتحده جل بايدن كانت ايضا حاضره ملك
وملكه هولندا وماليزيا وبلجيكا ولعهد
النرويج وولي عهد الدنمارك وشفنا ايضا
امير واميره ويلز ويليام وكاثرن اللي
كانوا وصلوا امس في الليل الى الاردن
وللتذكير كافر المشاهدين كانت عاشت في
الاردن لثلاث سنوات خلال طفولتها ودخلت
حضانه في الاردن وصور من وصول الثنائي
تزاولها طبعا الاردنيين بشكل واسع وكمان
صور من تواجدهم في مطعم احد الفنادق في
عمان ليلا
حقيقه الاهتمام بالزفاف الملكي مالي
الدنيا وكل العناوين والهاشتاقات اللي
بتتكلم عن الزفاف ترند من امس على المنصات
وتصميم نفرح بالحسين زين كل مكان في
الاردن وكمان انختم على كل جوازات اللي
داخلين الى الاردن ومو بس كده لا كمان
شفنا فيديوهات لحلويات
وزعوها على المسافرين على الخطوط الاردنيه
الخطوط الملكيه طبعا الاردنيه مكتوب عليها
نفرح بالحسين امس وحتى طيارات الملكيه
الاردنيه كمان تزينت بتصميم نفرح بالحسين
وبصور العروسين بهذه المناسبه وتم توزيع
الحلويات على الركاب
[موسيقى]